Best revenge, no stress, I still ain't missed
I could've got round there, put it on social media, I ruined his cred
Could've grabbed a haba, put two in his head, but I let God do it instead
A dumb man wrong, where are they now? Nowhere to be seen
Where they at? The power's strong, where am I now?
I've been in the charts for 18 weeks
My bro stayin' off him right now, make man tap out
But he stay on his team like a beep
Bro, I know it's long time, no see, but I'm here whenever you need
Sat in a band, no watches, not one good for my mental health
The things I see on a daily basis be on a daily melt
Why the hell would I dwell on the past when I make profit off the pain I felt?
How the fuck these guys gonna date these girls when they can't even pay for themselves?
Few of these females left me on red back then, but look, now I bet they regret it
They used to ask what I do for a living, I said that I work in a chemist
I had no money, I weren't embarrassed, I'm doing that road in my Toyota Yaris
C-Squad late, tryna cut through traffic, rule number one, don't panic
I know they hate it, they can't ignore me, I'm all over London town
It's funny to think that I went OT when I was 16 for a hundred pounds
I get Kyalizia now, true, L-Y-M-E, don't run them
I couldn't care less what they say on their blogs as long as my mum's eat proud
I keep on telling the yambos, brand on, quick cars all about